with travel rebounding in nearly every
sector travel expert janine tornatore
joins us to share what what she expects
this year from biggest comebacks
emerging trends and changing consumer
behavior hey janine
hi great to be here great to see you
again welcome back i know this is a
crazy season for travel because of
obviously the cobit surge so with the
heightened concerns during the holidays
do you think that consumers will
actually pull back on their 2022 travel
plans
you know i think amid this covid surge
we are seeing travelers being a little
hesitant for the
near term but when people are looking
further out there's still a lot of
demand for travel in 2022 so i think
what people are doing right now is
saying hey spring break summer travel
what should i be booking so you know
when we look out a little further past
this current surge there's a lot of
opportunity for travelers right now i'll
start with the cruise industry you know
they're being really flexible right now
with their cancellation policies but now
is really the time for travelers to look
at booking those trips further out in
the cruise industry now is what is
called wave season when all the biggest
promotions are on their websites you can
get the best deals so if you're thinking
about something later in the year this
is really the time to book those and
major travel brands like carnival
they're expecting their entire fleet to
be back by march back in service they're
doing their celebration events for their
50th anniversary there's gonna be a lot
going on on some of these big ships this
year okay good to know i feel like
people need something to look forward to
so traveling or planning ahead is a
great idea now how are these companies
actually planning for you know what
could be another unprecedented year
though
sure well you know they're certainly
telling folks to book early because i
think that when you see these big
seasons coming ahead you're going to
find there's going to be a lot of demand
and when we look for example on the
lodging side of things we're seeing that
some of the highest demand is for those
private vacation rental homes you know
now that everybody has these flexible
work cultures people can take longer
trips which they're planning to do and
so they're staying for longer they're
spending more um but travel sites are
also saying that people are booking
further out so for those vacation rental
homes they're booking two to three
months further out than we have in the
past so booking early is going to be
really key for travelers this year but
you know we are seeing you know a big
response to this travel demand
especially on the hotel side major
brands from marriott hyatt hilton they
are planning for lots of big luxury
hotel openings this year so the good
news on the front for uh travelers is
that you know more of these coming uh on
board means more inventory and hopefully
better rates for travelers that we love
the sound of that now what are your what
are your last tips you know for
travelers who are planning ahead right
now
well okay number one if you remember
back to 2020 when this pandemic first
hit a lot of people had vacations that
had to get canceled and so many people
were offered vouchers and credits well
2022 is the year that you're going to
start seeing those start to expire so if
you have credits way back when you
really need to check on them and use
them this year if they're about to
expire so make sure that you're checking
on those also this is really going to be
the year to plan the flexibility you
know all those cancellations we saw with
the airlines over the holidays those
labor shortages unfortunately that's not
going away anytime soon so this year
when you're planning make sure you're
really checking on what the supplier
policies are consider travel insurance
and just pack a lot of patience when
you're heading out oh pack your patient
we got it thank you so much i mean
always great advice and an update we
appreciate you
my pleasure all right safe travels jc
allison over to you pan